if you could talk to
vladimir putin once again
now
what kind of
what kind of things would you talk about
here what kind of questions would you
ask
well
one thing i would certainly ask is what
you were thinking on february 23 and i
would ask him to reply to my question
about
what if you took this to phase two you
you surrendered
in donbass you know no ego about it you
just surrendered it's in your interest
to your country and you invited all the
refugees from donbass into russia as
much as they can
what would you do now
what's the what's the us next move and
in your opinion how are you gonna
okay where are we gonna go that's that
would be the key question because it's
but he didn't go that way he chose to
take the sanctions and
and to go this way
why he did that is a key question for
our time
uh
perhaps it was a mistake perhaps it was
his judgment perhaps as i said but i
don't
knowing the man i did i don't think so i
think it was calculated
now this is projection and speculation
but there is something different about
him in the past
several months it could be the kovit
thing the isolation that you mentioned
yeah
i
listened to a lot of interviews and
speeches in russian
and there's uh there's something about
power over time that can change you that
can isolate you well when i was there no
he'd been in office for
already 15 years
he had power
he didn't misuse it in my opinion he was
very even i saw him go on television and
talk to his fellows the same way he
always talked to them
he grew with it he grew in intelligence
and knowledge because he had he had
dealings with the whole world now people
had come to him he was very well known
in africa and middle east certainly
syria
and
i i just never saw a misuse of his power
i saw humility in him actually so
perhaps
there was a calculation and he
calculated it wrong
in terms of what happens if he doesn't
invade
perhaps there was a calculation perhaps
he had a calm and clear mind
and he calculated wrong well he also
made the point that he had they took the
talk of zelensky saying
nuclear weapons were going to come into
ukraine there was talk about that right
before the invasion too and certainly
that would have set off alarms
you know the united states is already
kind of doing that
by not only putting its intelligence and
its heavy weaponry into ukraine but
you've got to deal with the question the
next question that comes up the most
immediate question is
is the united states
going to start
and i'm saying this is good
they they're making a lot of noise the
united states press about russia using
nuclear weapons and chemical weapons
that's a lot of noise
again going back to my analogy when the
united states starts that it starts the
conversation going it's in the interest
of the united states
for russia to be pinned with any kind of
chemical or nuclear
uh
incident exam for example it'd be very
not simple but it would be possible to
explode a nuclear device
in non-bass in donbass and kill
thousands of people
and we would not know right away who did
it but of course the blame would go
right to russia
right to russia even if it didn't make
sense if there was no motivation for it
it would just be blamed on russia the
united states might well be the one who
does that false flag operation it would
not be beyond them they would it would
be a very dramatic uh solution
to stealing this war off as a major
victory for the united states that's
terrifying no but it can happen it can
happen at one kiloton device low yield
this it's possible so when you walk
across that line you can potentially
never walk back
well i think the united states is
calculating that
it's a dangerous yes i agree but i think
the neoconservative arrogance is such
that they really believe they can push
their advantage to the max now
that because of all these propaganda
successes up to now the ukrainian army
could be wiped out for all we know
there's all that's left is our neo nazi
brigades but they're being advised very
well by the u.s
and they're sending the weapons in huge
amounts of weapons what about american
budget no one talks about how much money
we're giving to ukraine we get it's a
billion dollars already in weaponry and
not most of it just poured in what about
you know the the russian budget is
defense budget is 60 some billion
dollars a year it's nothing compared to
the united states one-fifteenth of it
but yet we we've put so much weaponry
into ukraine the money we've spent
on ukraine is all equivalent almost to
what we spent on on
coven in our own country it's astounding
the distortion of our priorities
uh there's also chemical don't forget
chemical is probably the easier way to
go but in syria there was far too many
incidents of of america
in its quest to
demonize
assad and the russians of all these
chemical attacks that were happening
that
they were vowing came from russia and uh
in spite of the fact that russia just
pulled out of the uh signed the
agreement on chemical arms and not and
apparently destroyed its stock several
years ago
it's it's strange that the the strangest
incidents happened in syria you go back
to him trace everyone
good journalism was done the white
helmets got a lot of fame but they were
corrupted and many good journalists
tried to point out the inconsistencies
in the american uh uh
accusations
robert perry among them uh who was one
of my mentors at consortium press a lot
of good journey you'd have to go back
but trace each like you would trace each
time you they made an accusation against
putin of murder
you need that same kind of sherlock
holmes intensity investigation and they
don't do it because the united nations
or the chemical
not the united nations as much as the
chemical people the uh the organization
has been tampered with if you remember
correctly there was accusations that the
chemical chemical uh
investigative unit i don't know the name
of
was tampered with
and people quit people who were working
on that commission quit and said that
this is not legit
it's a very interesting that serial
story is wacko
so the united states is willing to use
chemical in syria freely and did it
three four times if you remember
correctly trump was challenged that he
did not attack after a chemical incident
in syria
all these newscasters in the united
states uh the most heaviest of them were
saying well
president putin is uh president trump is
now finally acting like a real president
when he attacks when he drops missiles
in syria they actually said that in
other words they wanted the trump to go
to war on syria but he didn't chemical
weapons
nuclear is really terrifying do you
think now combine this
with the fascinating choice
in your interviews with vladimir putin
to watch stanley kubrick's
uh
doctor strangelove or how i learned to
stop worrying and love the bomb and
given the fact that that you did that
now looking at the fact that the word
nuclear
and it feels like
the world hangs on the brink of nuclear
war
do you
do you think that that's overstating the
case no
that's what worried me from the
beginning and that's probably why i got
involved in all this stuff because i i
go back to the uh
60s when i was a you know when we were
so close to nuclear war i lived through
that period and i thought as
many people did that this was
it was kind of it was going to come now
so i've lived through that
and some i didn't sense the period in 83
when reagan took us to the edge if you
remember correctly abel archer it was an
exercise
that almost brought us to an increase
the russians were
really paranoid at that point and they
were they were responding to our
military exercise on able archer there
was also the korean airliner they went
down there were numerous incidents in
the 80s but i never felt the fear
i thought reagan was
testing the limits but
perhaps if i'd been younger i would have
felt it but anyway no we come close the
united states has risked this several
times
if i told you it would be hard for you
to believe if i could set a scene for
you in a drama in a in in 1962 when
kennedy has a meeting with the joint
chiefs of staff
and the cia and they talk
about a plan
their military plan to uh
first strike the soviet union and china
okay it was called uh it was an
eisenhower plan that had been put into
operat put into a potential operation in
uh
in early 60s or 50s
late 50s
siop 62
this was an attack on the soviet union
first strike this that's why the united
states has never given up the concept of
first strike
is it's interesting that the russian
police nuclear policy posture is
more defensive than the american one
which leaves options open
it's the same options that are open in
neo-conservative uh agreements
that we see from the late 90s where they
say
the emergence of a rival power will not
be
tolerated that's a very broad statement
and it allows you to do a lot
including nuclear so
you have to understand the united states
is
always first of all it does it breaks so
many treaties i mean we know that from
the putin story about
the uh anti-ballistic missile treaty in
2002 and then the inf treaty of
the brit they broke that one that was
the intermediate
missile
that was 2019 i don't know when they
broke it off but the united states has
not been very faithful on its nuclear
agreements
and so
i don't know that we can even deal with
it united states diplomatically it seems
to be impossible
now brings me to biden
yes and this is another irishman this is
the opposite of kennedy kennedy was a
catholic irish
anti-imperialist biden seems to be the
opposite he seems to be a goal get along
go along guy who's been
not only old but he's also gone along
with this program which i voted for
biden because i i feared trump but i
thought biden at a certain age would
mellow i really did
he's not mellowed apparently he's still
listening to these people and he
believes them
and it seems that his uh
that horrible woman victoria nuland who
was under secretary of state appointed
her to these to this sector of the world
she's very influential and she's been
one of the
worst people on ukraine she obviously is
behind the coup she's she was the one
who boasted that uh you know
we got our man in yachts whatever is
yatsunuk
and also
remembers the famous statement [ __ ] the
eu all these things she's but she's back
and she said the other day about
if the soviets if the russians use uh
nuclear
weaponry of any kind there's going to be
a horrible price to pay that was uh she
was out of the blue i said what the hell
is she doing she's talking nuclear all
of a sudden and then since that day
everybody in the u.s press all the shows
have gone talk nuclear nuclear nuclear
secretary of state has done it uh
blinking
it scares you if you think about it the
united states scares me so that's the
military-industrial complex machine
fully functional fully operational
behind this whole thing is that is that
what's the blame it certainly is that's
why i showed him strange love because i
wanted him to show him i wanted mr putin
to say look at this film you never saw
it how can you not say you know it's a
seminal film in american history to
those people who care and it shows you
the
kubrick had a ant had a pacifist thank
god
anti-war
mentality which he showed in powers of
glory as well as strange love
and it's such a dire
well-done scenario that
i wanted mr putin to be aware of the way
the united states thinks
yeah the absurdity of escalation the
absurdity of war at the largest scale
the absurdity of nuclear war especially
can we walk back from the brink of
nuclear war
can we can we yes yes what's the path to
walk back
reason between hormones and diplomacy
there's no reason i mean
talk to the guy
mr biden
why don't you calm down and go and talk
to mr putin
in moscow why don't you just sit across
the table from
and try to have a discussion without
falling into ideologies and stuff like
that
you